hurricane ida has reached the louisiana
coast as one of the most powerful storms
ever to hit the united states the now
category 4 storm made landfall just
southwest of new orleans with maximum
wind speeds of around 240 kilometers an
hour this hurricane arrives on the 16th
anniversary of hurricane katrina which
devastated the region the national
hurricane center has warned of tidal
surges torrential rains and flooding
let's go straight to new orleans now
where reporter dave cohen is standing by
dave this is being called one of the
most powerful
hurricanes to ever hit the united states
you're just a few kilometers away from
where it made landfall what's happening
right now
well it is just a few kilometers in time
in terms of top sustained winds of being
a category 5 hurricane the most powerful
on the system used to rate hurricanes it
is blowing ashore now and it is leveling
community after community with that
surge and with those unbelievable winds
the national hurricane center says it
will leave places where the eye of ida
passes over uninhabitable for weeks or
months
now we mentioned hurricane katrina the
federal response back then was heavily
criticized what's the federal
preparation this time around
it's far better than it was last time
both in terms of infrastructure and in
terms of individuals the infrastructure
they've armored the levees in new
orleans in response to the failures in
katrina that left 80 percent of the city
flooded and some 2 000 people dead
they've made them higher stronger and
more resilient they've added flood walls
and floodgates and pumps and now they
say another katrina couldn't do what
katrina did the good news for new
orleans is ida while it is stronger than
katrina was has missed the city just by
a hair coming in to the west and it
looks like while the city will suffer
heavy damage some flooding from rain
vast power outages it won't be the
devastation we saw with katrina not in
the city in outlying areas it will be
bad or worse dave before i let you go i
do want to ask you i mean hurricane
katrina it's been 16 years but it's
still fresh in people's mind there's
particularly the people who've suffered
who lost family members and friends how
have they been preparing we did see
those you know traffic jams of people
trying to evacuate the area
i think more people were scared of ida
not only because of its massive strength
and forecast but also because it fell on
the anniversary of katrina i know
personally i was here for katrina i
watched katrina rip the city apart and
fill it with water and i saw the
devastation and the heartache it caused
and it made people emotional i think
maybe that's part of the reason we've
seen such a massive evacuation probably
the largest since katrina
dave cohen a reporter
in new orleans speaking to us about
hurricane ida there dave stay safe thank
you for joining us today
thank you for checking in on us
you